Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for
my day.
May 8th, 2017 what's going on?
How are you ? Oh, this is one of these days.
I don't want to do the podcast, you know? Oh,
I'm putting on a fucking brave face right now. I got the energy in my voice,
right? I'm trying to bring it for you.
You know what I'm really feeling inside
wohoo
is what I really feel like. Hey,
is it be bill burns any from any of Monday morning pie kit?
Um, just even doing that just brought my energy down to the fucking man.
I can't, I gotta sell it. Speaking of what she,
I was just watching that quiet Ryan documentary where it was like, uh,
now you're here now what the fuck you going to do? Whatever it's called. And uh,
they would have to,
Kevin Dobro died and they got this new guy who could really sound like him and
hit all the notes. I'm like the first fucking show.
He goes out there and he's just like, uh, you guys want to bang your head
in the drummer afterwards, Frankie Benelli was giving them shit going, dude,
you can't just see. Got a fucking sell it.
That's what I love about watching those documentaries.
It's just somebody in those bands,
especially with metal music in the 80s they just thought it was a bunch of
morons that were just out there. You know, just dumb people and then you,
you listen to them breaking down the show and it's like, yeah,
these guys completely get performance. They totally, Emma, why would you rent?
You would have to do that to sell the amount of records that they did,
but for some reason, because of the subject matter, you don't think that they,
you just think that doing it and they're not thinking about it out.
He just got off. We just fucking read the Guy, the riot act. He's now,
we got like a 20 foot by 20 foot stage and you're performing like three feet by
three feet. You're not, you're going to get out there. You gotta sell it.
You gotta sell it.
I would have loved to been at that show watching the rest of the band cause
they're all pros. No one out is sell it.
And then there's this one guy in the middle looking like he's doing the fucking
river dance, you know, with his hands down by his side, his feet cut,
jumping around, you know, dancing on one fucking square piece of linoleum.
Linoleum. Um, it's a great word, isn't it?
It's a no Liam. It's a good name for a band, isn't it? Some glam band.
You just call it linoleum. They hit golf.
If you could sing a couple of songs about pledge, you know what?
Some other cleaner and that's just your thing. That's a wide open lane.
Nobody's ever done that. I might, I might go on a fucking that, hey,
that's my band name. Dot Net registered to seven bucks.
Whatever they charge. I love you. You can just register shit online.
Like when what it was, was this going to some guy's house?
Why are you acting like this is some governmental building, is that a word?
Governmental. Federal Lentil. How do you say it?
The Federal Reserve is no more federal than Federal Express.
Some Guy Tears up at 20. Right? And everybody dives on it,
fucking tapes it back together and then goes buys themselves as sub Blimpie.
Now what are you gonna say to your buddy? What are you telling me next?
The world is flat. I'm not that, I don't agree.
Not that I don't agree with that hypothetical person. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead here. How are you, how was your Monday?
I was going to get up this morning and get on the elliptical and uh, I did not,
I woke up this morning and felt like I played three years in the NFL and what I
did last week was I really researched what the fuck I was doing wrong with my
leg workout, you know, cause you know,
I have thighs of steels but buns of applesauce
and I'm not talking about the fucking job.
And when I realized was that my fucking my, for whatever that for you,
my quads were doing all the work right then my ass was just like some lazy dude
just fucking going along for the ride.
You know like that person when you're at the four top and the check comes at the
end of the night and everybody's digging in their pockets and stuff and that
person just kind of fucking, oh man Ya, you're not going to believe this.
I left my wallet at home. I'm dead. Right.
That's what my ass is like.
It's like the fucking dude who doesn't throw in at the end of the fucking night.
You know, he always come up short. You always come up short.
It's the guy who collects the fuck. I stupid about this.
The guy who collects the money,
you know everybody throws in 20 bucks to somebody. You always 10 bucks short.
It's the guy who collects the money. He's the guy who fucking,
he shorted because once he collects the money,
all he's going to say is how much you have and what you need and he's just going
to keep counting. You know, and then eventually one of you guys,
he's just going to fucking cave, ought to be in like, you know,
not liking confrontation and then you're going to throw in and then this fucker
got his meal for $5, $6, $7 less. All right.
So anyways, um,
I got this new workout that I'd been doing and uh, I did that.
And then the other night, you know,
I had already worked out that day and I went out in the garage,
sort of stretched and then skipped rope for fucking three rounds.
And I woke up this morning. Oh my God. I felt like, you know,
I felt like I ran a marathon. Sometimes I forget my age.
Um, you know, fucking cracks me up as people tell me I'm an old dead. It's like,
no I'm not. I'm not. When you really look at it, when you go around, I mean,
as far as my, my age, yes I am, but the physical shape I'm in. No.
Cause this is what this is. This is the in of me and you guys can argue this.
I'm not saying I'm old to be a dad, but I'm not an old debt. All right?
Cause this is what happens if you even have a kid at fucking 25 I see people who
had a kid at 25 I see what they look like at 35 alright,
you have to finish in the kids food and doing all of that shit.
Whatever the fuck it is they do. You know their body's did done.
They've finished. All right. I'm still doing pull ups.
48 fucking years old. I'll get on a bike. You know I skipped rope. I don't know,
maybe I need a new pair of those fucking Steve Job, new balance.
You know the classic old White Guy Sneakers. What's are now those sketchers
that is now the official, my fucking feet hurt old white guy,
not even old white guy. Cause those dudes,
Shaq and all of them wear it on a does it TNT or TBS. I always get it confused.
Whatever channel the basketballs on, you know,
whenever that one dude gets up and he goes over to the giant flat screen TV,
um, and then wearing like the suit and they got the fucking sneakers on,
you know
this,
there's nothing worse than the old guy fucking sneakers. All right.
Hang on a second. I've got to fucking, hang on. All right. I'm back.
I don't what was going on there? Son was like,
I was on a fucking airplane and my nose was closing up. Um, AH, shit.
And I forgot what the hell I was talking about. Oh, so much sketches. Yeah,
that is the official, it's just, it's, it's fucking over. You know what I mean?
Like if I was a gold dig, digging whore, you know, I go to the steak houses,
you know,
with a fucking rich fucking dudes hanging out and that's all I'd be looking for.
I look for that fucking guy in the sketches and I'd be like, all right,
this guy's got no fight left in him.
Oh, you do as bat your eyes at them and then that's it. Oh my God,
you fucking hobbles over. You're like, wow,
those are really interesting shoes. Oh, you cease. Get all excited about them.
It's like a walking on a cloud. Yeah. Why?
Once you walk on a cloud over your fucking ATM,
I'm telling you right now this [inaudible] if you're a fucking old rich dude
right now, do not get a pair of sketches. All right? You might as well have a,
a please gold. Dig me. Sign on the back of your fucking sport coat,
you know? Um, anyway, speaking of that,
I'm fucking worried about a, I'm not going to say the guy's name.
There's a fucking guy. I'm watching sports. He's fucking huge now.
He's fucking huge. Just can't be that big. Can't be that big.
You stuck getting in those fucking, those ages. You know,
you retire a couple of years, you just blow up. It's not going to be good.
You know, I was watching that quiet right thing as I mentioned. And um,
you know,
they always made it seem like fucking the lead singer Kevin Dobro like died
under like a mountain of cocaine and it really wasn't.
He had a little bit of cocaine,
a little bit of value in a little bit of alcohol and that they'll still fucking
a, you know the Quincy Guy there,
the Jack Klugman Quincy Guy was sitting there saying that once you get past a
certain age, he goes, you can't do that. You just can't do that today. Hey man,
we'll fucking ramping it up now.
We're slowing it down and we're going to level it out. You Heart's just like,
you know what? Fuck this about that.
I'm calling the shots now, not you. That's how it goes down.
You know? So anyways, getting back to that thing, all these fucking,
I'm telling you, you look at any dad, 10 years in Dell,
90% of them just can throw that out there without any research.
So like 30 pounds over fucking weight. All right.
I have lost weight since I've had a kid. The,
I'm not going to be the fat dad. I am not. I'm not going out like that.
I'm just not much saying, you know, at some point, you know, gravity takes over,
you know?
Okay.
I don't give a shit. I'm adjusting. I'm not fighting nature. I'm, I mean,
I'm trying to stay in fucking shape, but you know, I just, whatever,
you know, some of my hair started leaving. I was like, you know what?
Fuck all of you. I'm out shaved, done. What now? What next?
Yeah,
you can't go here. Plugs. You can't fucking do it. It's a slippery slope.
You know, you start doing that Michael Jackson Shit. Did he let go?
What if I had a booty chin? Ah, would that make me feel good about myself?
And you get the botox and you get the fucking, do they have,
do they have like fake like man pecs yet? You know,
and you can walk in and, and pick like the chest you want, like off the wall
testicles, whatever the fuck they call pex. You know, I'm, I'm,
I'm looking for like a Ben her meets, uh,
can Proterra. I didn't know what you would do.
I bet that's what it's going to be like in the future.
Everybody's gonna be like, uh, you're gonna be like a Resto Mod, right?
Where it's going to be like I'm going to be a 1968 white male heterosexual.
Right? But under the hood I'm going to have like a fucking,
you know this the fucking zoo. Six 26 that'll be a heart, right?
You get a brand new fucking heart brand new flocking high.
That's like some Saifai Shit. You know where it's like,
Oh God, this is so fucked up. You'd have two kids.
One kid would be your real kid and the other kid would be like the donor for the
foul bell. Why?
Why would you do that now? Cause you couldn't do that.
That's what rich people would do. Rich people. Okay.
Once they have like all the robots around them,
Manchez isn't a fucking movie right here.
They got all the rope robots garden them. Right?
And the only reason why they keep fucking people alive is that they need to like
harvest their parts,
but they don't want the fucking poor people to completely rebel and take out a
couple of their robots because it probably would be the same amount of money.
He's like a fucking FAA teen. Right? So what they'll do is they'll say,
all right, poor people, you're allowed to have like, you know,
four kids and for every four kids you have like, you know,
two of them gotta be donors or something like that. You know what I mean?
So like when I get to the age of, you know, I got to start wearing sketches,
you know, you come in and you fucking take the feet, you know, ah, God pill.
It's so fucking dark. I know it is. I know it is.
I've just been in a really dark place. I don't know.
There's something about becoming a parent. You just start thinking about them.
The most horrific fucking shit that could possibly happen,
you know, I swear to God,
Shit that used to kind of bug me now like really bugs me, you know,
if I see anything on TV of somebody like abusing a kid,
obviously that always bugged you, but once you fucking have one, you just like,
you just started thinking like, man, they should just,
people who do that should,
they should be lit on fire and then right before they die you put them out.
I don't know what you would call that. Punishment.
Okay.
What do you call that? Uh, what do they call that when you fucking,
when you cook a fucking steak. Siri. Yeah, we'll good.
We're going to Syria. That's what we're going to do. You sear it?
Keep all the fucking vitals together. No pill. Jesus Christ. You know,
we listen to this podcast bill to get away from our troubles. All right,
fair enough. Fucking fair enough.
Um,
I had a fun day yesterday when I wasn't watching the Celtics just get the shit
kicked out of him in the second half, you know,
but I know we're gonna win game six. I don't even know that.
I hope we're gonna win game six. You know,
I want to let people learn not to talk shit cause it just motivates the other
fucking team. And then fans don't get that either. I didn't see it, you know,
goes busy this weekend. Had family in town visiting my daughter and um,
I guess someone on the Celtics, I don't know if it was green, said yeah,
we're definitely going to beat him in the next game. It's like,
why would you do that?
That thing that fucking wall did on a Instagram alone to that guy in the Atlanta
hawks. You know, this guy fucking thrives off a grudge.
Why the fuck would you do that so that the wizard fads come on in?
I think they just saw the results of shit talk, right?
And I'm watching the Celtics walk off the court after a loss and you see two
fucking Goddamn, you know,
cotton candy eating fatties not even fat, but just dad bods.
Just clap and go, hey, great job. Great job. Like yelling at the Celtics.
Is that going off the court? It's like he fucking moron.
Why would you do that? You don't say anything. You cheer politely.
You let them walk and then that's it and you let doubt slip into their fucking
head. You don't fucking yell at a professional athlete.
You think they're going to implode. This isn't a field goal kicker.
Yeah,
someone's got the balls to go down the fucking lane, right?
All that's going to do is motivate them. You Guy,
you guys never learned that Shit fucking morons.
And I'm talking to Celtics fans too, cause they also do it, you know,
I hate those people. Like right after they win a game,
they just got fucking talk all this shit, you know,
Celtics get that ass slapped all that shit. It's like, dude, it's two,
two and then they're gonna disappear to the abyss. If we went another two,
they'd fucking happens every time. So we'll see. Um,
I want to say that the Celtics won't win the next game and then I think we lose
in Washington and then it just becomes like,
what team is going to win on the road or is the home team going to hold,
serve the bed, dead, dead, dead, dead, dead. It, they,
what am I fucking do in the NBA? Thank you. I've gotta be honest with you,
as much as I, I've really come back to the NBA and I enjoyed it. I,
when I'm watching an NBA game, when there's an NHL game and I flip over to it,
it's not even close to the level of fucking excitement.
It's people jogging up the court versus people like skating around doing like
2030 miles an hour slamming into each other,
basketball people that are all about, oh, there's no scoring,
which I understand.
It's one of my big complaints about when you watch soccer other than the fucking
flopping, which by the way, Jesus Christ,
did you guys see what's his face doing?
His salmon up the river set guys named Biel or whatever on, on DC,
and you just see all the fucking memes about that guy.
That was one of the worst. If he just dove, that would have been fine.
But the way he threw his head back,
good Lord. Fucking quiet riot ought to have him as a front man.
He'd fucking sell every goddamn song, doubt without a doubt. But I'm,
I gotta admit I, you know,
hockey's just where it's at and I've got an IOS app to apologize.
The Ottawa Senators, I was watching that fucking game the other day.
And uh, what was it? The a rangers was a, what was the score?
Were they up four to three? Is that what it was?
Just go with the fourth goal with like seven minutes to go.
And I'm rooting for the range is why I hate New York expelled sports fans,
you know, can't stand them. But Ottawa beat my Bruin so I'm like fuck it.
And I always got like a soft spot spot for the ranges cause I rooted for them in
94 to win the company. That's one of the great, you know,
runs I ever saw in sports. So I'm rooting for him. Right.
Plus I've got a couple of friends in a big range offense, so it's four to three.
It gets down to like a minute and change left. And I'm thinking,
Oh and I've got family coming over, right? I got to go downstairs,
I gotta fire up the flat top, going to make some Burgers,
a little bit of Hash browns. I don't do French. I go hash browns.
I go hash browns on a flat top grill and I'm like French fries,
French fries past a certain fucking age. He just can't do it.
They just take it down to the met. It's not the Burgers, it's the fries,
it's not the pizza. It's the soda or maybe it's the combination of the two.
That's probably what it really is. When you have both of them, it's just like,
it's fucking over, right. So minute change. I feel like I'm fine.
I'll go downstairs, you know, brothers over here.
Couple of Bud hods right.
I come back in the fucking house and he's like, he's like Ottawa one.
Like, what do you mean they fucking won? What? How do they win?
Tied it up with like no time left. And they, then they gave me all right there,
Fred and overtime. Anyways, um,
my apologies to the Ottawa senators. I just did not believe in them.
Evidently they're for real and I think they're going to take this series.
See what it just did there?
It made it sound like I was saying something positive about Ottawa,
but any real sports fans knows what I'm doing right now.
I'm trying to put a hex on him.
The Old Ronnie Hextall. Now I'm fucking with the, um,
I keep forgetting the rangers are like a wild card. I Dunno.
Fuck it. Anderson. Dude, that guy's these easy guy.
Everybody keeps talking about the dude with a busted foot,
skating around their Carlson, whatever the hell his name is. I can't, I,
you know, once,
once the Russians came in and all the east and the Finnish people,
I haven't been able to remember anybody's fucking name. Really. Bill,
you're going to blame that or your lack of short term memory. All right,
maybe you got me. Maybe that's what it is. All right,
let me type in my password here and let's see. Let's see. Uh, let's see.
We got coming up here. I've got to do a little bit of advertising here. Oh Man.
19 minutes and now, Whoa, Whoa, wait. We will talk about who the fuck is this?
Bonna Masa live on tour near you get tickets.
Now these shows will sell up this fucking guitars.
This flyer has been on everything I've looked at.
I don't know what I clicked on. I don't know what I clicked on. Well,
here's the article I clicked on.
Two engaged doctors found bound in slain in luxury Boston penthouse suspect in
custody after shootout.
Who the fuck is ed?
She said that somebody is 39th birthday tomorrow and I have no idea who it is.
He's fucking computers, man. I don't, I don't know.
I don't know what's going on with them. Um, all right, so two doc,
two doctors or engaged. One was 49 right?
The other was 39 right. Or 38
Boston police entered the 11th floor, penthouse apartment. Friday night.
They found a gruesome scene, which I'm not going to talk about.
Luxury condo and this is what kills me about this whole story. No Pun intended.
Levon
floor, luxury penthouse in Dorchester. You know,
I know I moved away in 1995 I know that's 22 years ago,
but the fact that there's a luxury penthouse, the two doctors are living in,
in Dorchester's is an unbelievable,
I met when I was a kid that talk about what Dorchester used to be.
They used to say, oh, this used to be this upscale place and blah, blah, blah.
Then it became blue collar and then the fucking crack eighties cat at did an old
fuck it. That goes to shit. Right. The thing that it's now back.
This is what I don't understand.
It's like every neighborhood now is becoming high end. It's like where,
where is everybody else going to go?
I really hope we don't end up like a third world country where it's just like,
you know, if you have a been to one,
it's like you'll see like these ridiculous mansions and you know,
and a gated community with people like with like fucking machine guns standing
outside of them and then everybody else was living in a fucking tin shack. Um,
I don't know. Is that what, what I was supposed to get out of that story?
I mean obviously make a dominance goes out to those two people and they caught
the fucking Douche bag with did it Luna tick Trump's war on science continues
with EPA firings, president Trump's war on basic facts continues,
but this time you literally end up choking on it. Oh, Jesus Christ.
What is it about, why do Republicans just act like the earth is just
okay?
You know, like it's not a finite thing.
Yeah,
I just don't understand it. I get that you have companies,
I get that you're sick of the tree huggers going, hey man,
you're putting too many greenhouse gases.
I understand that that becomes annoying to you because all you stare at is your
fucking bottom line. But like, I just don't understand those fucking people.
They just sit, there's plenty of wine. Let it's a lake over there.
You know what the fuck they call. They just look at it like that.
I just don't understand it. Um,
I think that they're just so fucking psycho competitive or just so unbelievably
selfish. Really like, well, even if what the tree huggers are saying is true,
it's not going to happen in my lifetime. And even it does.
I'll be too old to give a fuck.
Um,
Facebook's war against fake news in the UK is long overdue.
What is Facebook concerned with? You know, the, I don't like that guy.
I don't like that fucking guys, Zuckerberg,
whatever his fucking name is that runs this thing said since, what? Why,
why is he so fucking involved in fake news?
You have a site that's for people to like, you know,
figure out who the fuck they going to bang that they used to went to high school
with. In November, Facebook, CEO,
Mark Zuckerberg said the idea that so-called fake news could influence the u s
election was quote crazy.
Can you guys read between the lines here? It's all fucking fake. It's all spun.
This guy, you know what this guy is right now. This guy is like,
he's a made guy and now he has a dog in the fight.
So now this fucking dope now, but he's not dope. Obviously.
He started this fucking, this little fucking Chitchat site. Um,
now he's going to decide what is real and what is fakes.
So maybe you said it was crazy that he couldn't have influenced it. Bill,
maybe you should read the whole article before you throw this billionaire under
the bus. Okay, fair enough. Sorry mark. Uh,
six months later, however,
the social network has announced an all out war on misinformation and hoaxes in
the UK before the general election in June. Uh, I see, I see. You know what,
he either got paid off or he got a phone call about a convertible ride in
Dallas. That's what somebody just called up, you know,
he just picks it up, picks up the phone, hello Facebook. Right?
And then he just had that, you know that voice they always have, you know,
whenever they have like the gang members on TV, like your old fridge,
no more full grown going have grab and go group your up rear. Right.
They had like that voice except it was like Illuminati hitman calling up,
you know, he's like, hey, easy mark Facebook.
How may I help you? [inaudible]
order we're going to an apple be wears. Um, something like that.
They scared the shit out of them. You know what you know,
you scare the shit out of a fucking nerd. You just take his phone away,
you take his phone away and then you've threatened to burn one of his superhero
costumes and that motherfucker will tell you anything you want.
So now he's having this all out war on fake news out of what the fuck does y um,
how do you tell what is fake? And what isn't. Everybody's lying.
Everybody's a fucking lie.
How many lies do you think Hillary and Trump told combined?
And just one debate. You got two piles of Shit.
Just say the other one smells worse, right? Isn't that what it is?
Everybody's lying all fucking thing. You know, I still don't understand.
And Iowa, I know I always say this, whenever a bill gets passed,
why did they always have to?
Why are they allowed to tag on all these other fucking things?
I've never understood it. Anyway, six months later, the guys,
he's an all out war on misinformations and hoaxes in the UK. Oh,
that's because they, they voted to leave the European Union,
which probably fucked with the bankers who want to have everybody all unified
all on one currency that they are fucking printing.
So inadvertently people just saying, hey man, let's get the fuck out of here.
And now you've got to have an all out war. And that's what happened.
The bankers hitmen call this guy up, right? All right.
Facebook is tweaking its algorithms to try to halt the spread of misinformation.
Giving users tips on identifying sources designed to misinform and an even ran
full page advertisements in British newspapers on Monday.
Reiterating how to spot misinformation online. I want to,
I want to say you can see the full advertising times meant below, out once.
See what they got here. Alright, tips for spotting false news.
One, the person you're talking to is wearing a trench coat with the fedora and
sunglasses. Alright. Be Skeptical of headlines.
You know what?
They just took a picture of the newspaper so I can't see this here.
Look closely at the URL. Investigate the source.
Watch for unusual formatting.
Consider the photos, inspect the dates. Check the evidence.
Look at other reports. Is The story a joke?
Some stories are intentionally false.
I don't know if you use this algorithm for Facebook, would,
would Facebook still exist? I mean, the whole fucking thing is fake.
Everybody picks takes a picture.
They hold the camera up over their fucking face.
So that drops like 40 pounds in upstate number from a four to a six and six to
an eight.
Right.
Everybody photoshops does all that shit was,
it wasn't y'all Kungfu Kenny talking about that new song.
I don't fucking know what,
why do I claim some of Wall Street's top boutique firms just landed a big payday
and for some reason they have a picture of a z's and sorry. I mean,
is it that misinformation right there? Jesus. Sorry, is not one of
the Wall Street's top boutique firms is Izzy. That's misinformation.
He's a stand up comedian as far as I know.
Um,
all right. I think, I think I've fucking filibustered long enough avenue.
Okay.
You know what's funny? When I think of Mark Zuckerberg,
I don't think of Mark Zuckerberg.
I think of the fucking guy that played him in the movie. And you know,
when I look at Mark Zuckerberg, he looks way more than, yeah,
okay.
MMM. Okay. Oh Jesus. Mother's Day's coming up, you know,
so you know what you gotta get or you gotta get it. So Sherry's berries.
Talk about your favorite story about your mom or talk about a television mom you
really admire and why? You know what,
I always wanted a bang Alice on that show. Alice, there was something about her,
you know what I mean?
She was like 39 40 so you knew what she was doing in the rack. You know,
she had that Charlie's angels haircut. She could sing a little bit. You know,
she's busy, she's got a couple of kids. She's not going to fuck around.
She's going to look at you like you want to do this. So what?
How do you want to do it? And I'd be like, keep the uniform on.
Alright,
mother's Day is coming up in Sherry's berries is offering huge,
freshly dip strawberries starting at 1999 plus shipping.
And right now I have an exclusive offer to you that is only available on this
podcast and the other 15,000 they advertise on when you double the berries.
Oh Jesus. Mom's getting a threesome here. Uh,
for mom for just $10 more. She will get free cake.
Truffles, free cake truffles too.
That's like a whole extra gift for free. Uh,
pick your delivery date and Sherry's berries guarantees your gifts will arrive
fresh and delicious or your money back. That's not like two gifts.
If you get, if you get Sherry's barrier, then cake truffles.
That's like you took your girl out for pizza and you got the old Mozzarella
sticks and then when you can say, I took you out for two meals.
Okay,
no you didn't. You got me a fucking appetizer in a couple of slices.
Then you manhandled me in your Chevy Vega. All right,
pick up your delivery date at Sherry's berries. Pick your delivery date. Sorry.
At Sherry's berries,
guaranteed your gifts will arrive fresh and delicious or your money back.
Please use this time to tell your listeners about the Sherry,
about what your Sherry's berries look like tasted like and your overall
impression of them. A chocolate covered strawberries. Gross me up.
I don't know what it is.
There's something about them because they're always used in like a sexual kind
of way.
That was like a cheesy thing when I grew up to have like chocolate covered
strawberries. Then you had like a heart shaped fucking bed that vibrated,
which I also never understood. You know what I mean?
Like who would want to bang while driving over a gravel road at 40 miles an
hour? Evidently people in the 70s, you know what it was, is they,
they didn't trim their pubes so they had enough of a cushion. Um,
anyway, she may think you've seen gourmet dip strawberries before.
I never said that. Uh, but you have never seen anything like these.
Sherry's berries are huge, sweet, juicy and covered in decorated toppings.
Chocolate chips, chocolate nuts,
white milk, Caucasian,
dark chocolate, Puerto Rican, goodness.
Sherry's berries are an unexpected gift that will put a smile on my any mom's
face. My mom's to, um, see I've read,
this is one I three on dyslexic cause I saw the y in any,
and then I saw the m in mom and then that board becomes Ma my,
see I wasn't dumb all those years in school. Surprise the mom in your life.
That's pretty vague. We share these berries at our office slash.
Workplace, otherwise be that great kids book. Are you mother?
The only way to get amazing berries deals starting at just not poor fucking
bird. Imagine how many strawberries that
thing@abuyatjustnineteenninetynineyouvisitberries.com.
Click on the microphone at the top right hand corner and use my code bur bur.
That's berries.com. B, e. R. R. I. E. S Can Code Burger. You know what?
They should have used chuck berry to do this. Now he's passed away.
When you click on the mic,
the amazing deal won't last long and mother's Day is right around the corner.
It's this Sunday, everybody and I n so be sure to order now. Oh,
and after you get to the chocolate covered strawberries,
get her some flowers to apologize for the fact that her hips are going to
expand. proflowers.com everybody
talk about what things you still go to your mom slash a mother figure four
advice on, dude, I'm fucking 48.
I cut the cord a long time ago. I just called my mom up to tell her I love her.
Uh,
when you send a hundred blooms for your mom bouquet or Bocquet from pro flowers,
this mother's Day, you will make a real impression.
You know what I do every once in a while for making a family recipe.
I'll call her up and be like, mom, I can't read your writing here.
And what is that? Um,
it comes with a free glass vase for just 1999 plus shipping and handling.
I mean, if you really wanna make a statement,
you can upgrade to a premium vase and include gourmet chocolates for just $10
more.
Choose the delivery date you want and pro flowers are guaranteed to arrive fresh
and beautiful and stay that way for at least seven days or your money back.
Please use this time to tell your listeners about what pro flowers bouquet
bouquet look like and your overall impression of it. Well,
I don't have one, so I don't know. I imagine it looks, I imagine it's,
it's an explosion of color, you know,
leaving its host the vase, right? Reaching up to the sun,
wondering why it's feet got cut off. Mother's love,
fresh flowers in pro flowers.
Make it easy to send the perfect mother's Day gift with this huge bouquet.
Don't forget all the moms in your life, mom, grandma, wife,
and other mother figures this mother's Day. Jesus Christ.
Can these cons make enough money? Any woman walking down the street? Hey Lady,
are you a mom? Well, you will be. Here's some flowers.
The only way to get 100 blooms for mom with a free glass face starting at 1999
is to visit pro flowers.
Click on the microphone in the top right hand corner and use my code bar.
That's Plouffe pro. flowers.com. Um,
okay.
Borough slash bar. Uh, when you click on the mic, oh,
use my code bar. Okay, I see you got a profiles.com and click on the Mike, uh,
the and you type in borough. Okay. The stunning bouquet sells out fast.
So ordered today. All right, upside. Sorry,
I fucked up the end of that. I mean,
I would tell you why I fucked up the end of that.
Cause I'm going to see my mother for this mother's Day. And uh,
I'm actually going to go to this fucking chocolate place down the street to get
mine, uh, upside. There's a better way for you to buy business travel.
It's called upside.com. Every time you buy trip it upside,
you'll save your company a ton of money, you know,
and don't feel like reading this fucking shit. There's three more of them.
I don't want to do this. I don't want to talk about this.
Let's just fucking let me just give my brain a break. All right.
Um, so anyways, yesterday I did this thing. Uh,
it was the Ronnie James Dio, uh, ride for cancer, uh,
which I, it should be a ride to fight cancer,
but he said it was a ride for cancer. I was like, buddy,
these people for cancer cause people fans of disco.
And then I showed up and it was a bunch of people with fucking Harley Davidson's
in, in, in, you know, knives on their hips and shit. I was like, no,
these guys are fighting cancer. Okay, I get it. Um,
so I show up at this thing was an Encino outside of this park.
And I come walking in and I'm going to introduce Steven Adler's all star band
that he's putting together, right. And they're going to play a few songs.
Eddie money was there. He was fucking hilarious. Fucking hilarious.
Um, everybody there, like,
I don't know everybody that was just fucking killing it and had like a sense of
humor about, you know, cause they were outside.
It started raining a little bit and um, so I walk in there going like,
all right,
so they want me to joke around a little bit in intro the band and it's outside.
The Sun's out and then it starts fucking raining. It's a bunch of bikers.
This one guy walked in, I so swear to God on his, the back of his belt,
he had this fucking sheet knife. It was like a fucking 10 inch blade.
It's like, what are you going to do with that? You know,
what the fuck are you going to do with that thing?
That's not to defend yourself? You're going to murder anybody.
Maybe that's what it is. People see that and it's just, dude,
this guy could kill a fucking bear with this thing. Um,
so I'm just thinking, Oh God, this is how, how was this going to go? Right.
So I'm watching the bands and I'm enjoying everybody yet in the back of my head
going like, well, how the fuck am I gonna deal with this?
Eddie trunk was there and he was in trolling the band and they were being nice
and polite to him. So I was thinking, all right,
but he's not trying to be funny, even though he was being funny,
but he wasn't billed as a standup comedian. So, um,
I ended up going up there, joked around a little bit.
They laughed and I intro the band,
I turned around and then of course they'd give me the stretch sign, you know,
because it had finally stopped fucking rain and they will get rid of the, the,
the four posted canopy that they had over the drum kit. And, uh,
I actually joked around and went, good. I had a great fucking time.
And it took me back to when I used to do college gigs,
the college gigs were the,
were the worst cause you'd show up as an unknown comedian and they would fucking
stick you anywhere outside, inside raining,
snowing. They didn't give a fuck cafeteria hallway, Mike.
No, Mike, you don't think he'd come up,
walk out of that walk in closet?
It just took me back to those days and like really having to fight to get the
crowd. And I ended up having a great time. And um,
it was great, man. I got to watch fucking, uh, Adler play again. And you know,
it was killing me was, he does a lot of those fucking three in the row.
And then on the bass drum, you know, just playing even like eighth notes at a,
at a, like a mid tempo. But the way he puts him in really propels the song.
So I'm watching him play welcome to the jungle.
And the last time I watched a play, I figured out something that he was doing.
So this time I'm watching his footwork. All right.
And is this fucking guy taking picture of him every time he goes to do that
thing like, and I'm starting to get it.
This guy keeps getting in my way and then like I had this,
then the camera man finally got out of the way and I'm getting to watch him play
a whole verse and it's common. I have this anxiety going, please,
please don't anybody fuck this up. Don't anybody fuck this up.
All of a sudden I feel this tap on the shoulder and go pick fell apart.
Just say, get a picture as I, I have too much of a need to be liked to say,
hang on a second so I fucking missed it again
because my ears aren't good enough the way they've mixed it.
You know what I mean? With the Bass and the bass drum,
sometimes I can't tell z did he? Do you know what?
What's he playing right there? I Dunno. I Dunno. It's,
we'll be a lifelong fucking obsession, but I've got to watch them do that.
Lead a Ford came out saying,
sweet child of mine and then they played rocket queen. He fucking murdered it.
And uh, and I had a great time, so thank you to uh,
everybody at that event who showed up, um,
to raise money for cancer. Um, you know,
always the best was at one point they was singing a dio song and uh,
let's tell my buddy bought this. And first of all,
I'm looking at all the people in the fucking crowd and they're all my age and a
little bit older and I'm just like, wow, man, we are fucking old. Right?
But everybody's having a great time and this fucking fucking dude,
five foot, nothing goes up there.
I saw him on another event and he somehow related to Rania doesn't know.
I don't know if he's an a personally, I don't know what, but he key, hey,
he really captures
like Ronnie's ranging really can sound like him. And he started singing it,
dude in the crowd. There was this one fucking guy in the crowd, man,
he fucking lost it. He still had the Vince Neil haircut,
not the teased up one when it's just fucking laid down and he had like a fucking
keg cup filled with beer. Well into his 50s, you know,
so he's got the whole dad bod and shit.
He lost his fucking mind cause I knew this guy was good.
So I was looking in the crowd cause I wanted to see their reaction.
This guy just fucking
lost it. He's pointing it. He started pointing at the singer with like,
you know, doing the double point while holding his, he was just like
looking at his friend. His eyes are all wide, couldn't fucking believe it.
And I was thinking like that was a kid when I would go to go see these bands who
was above five years older than me, you know, already had like the fucking awful
mustache going and you know,
and he'd have some hot skanky looking chick with some fucking pink and black,
you know, leopard print a spandex on, you know.
And I was sitting there with my fucking, uh, you know, Ralph Mouth Look,
you know, couldn't grow. My hair would never grow down. It would just grow out.
It looked like fucking Bernie from room two 22. And I just always think like,
yeah man, Fide Brown, flat hair, man.
I could get one of those spandex chicks. He used to think that shit.
Rather than thinking like,
why don't you just fucking have a little confidence to say alo? You know,
this is the one thing, no matter how fucked up you look,
you have to hold onto the fact that you gotta be somebody fetish.
There's always hope. You know what I mean? You're not ugly.
You just haven't met somebody who's into what you're doing or what the fucking
hand you were dealt. Okay.
And if anything tells me that it's when you watch those storage wars,
because to me that's just a bunch of shit. I don't want any of it.
And everybody's fucking everybody else's freaking out. Like, Dude, look at that.
That's a dark board. I think that's a dartboard in that case. My God,
that's a refrigerator. You think there's food in there,
you know the shit that they're looking at. You know, maybe that's what you are.
Maybe physically what you look like.
You're the human version of what they find in those storage sheds. You know?
And if you've got a great heart, but God dammit,
you're like one of those original civil war fucking muskets. I'm all right.
That was positive. That was a positive thing. So I think it's timely.
You know what? I think I can do a little more advertising that.
Um, okay. Upside everybody. Second attempt coming around again. Um,
you might've heard this earlier in the podcast.
Evidently there's a better way for you to buy business travel.
It's called upside.com. Every time you buy a Goddamn trip it upside,
you'll save your company a ton of money and they give you a gift card,
an Amazon gift card worth hundreds of dollars.
That doesn't make any sense. I mean,
a fucking plane tickets about 300 bucks and you're going to give me $200 where
the DVDs, how are you making any money?
Upsides able to do this because they bundle your flights and hotels together for
one low price. Bundled pricing saves money.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
your company saves a ton of money and you could get fast thousands a year in
gift cards just by buying your air and hotel together upside. Plus,
you'll still get all your miles if you're shopping for business travel.
You'd be crazy not to check out upside.com.
It just takes three minutes to see how much you've saved by buying your flights
and hotel together for one low price. I can't even read.
I can't even see the words anymore. I don't know what happened.
My eyes are fatigued here right now. When you use my name Barbie, you are are,
you're guaranteed to get at least a $100 Amazon gift card your first trip.
That's my neighbor. To get at least a $100 Amazon gift card for free.
Save big on travel and get big gift card every time.
Uh,
evidently I love upside.com upside.com minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details. All right, two more. Two more.
Jesus fucking Christ bell. Here we go. Dollar Shave club dough.
You got hair on your face. You want to get rid of it.
You don't want to spend a zillion dollar or dollar shave club is the smarter
choice. You'll get a great shave at a great price,
conveniently delivered right to your goddamn door.
You no longer have to Schlep to the fucking store.
Buy a cheap disposable razors that gave you a cheap shave or spend a fortune on
razors with gimmicky shaving technique, a technology you didn't even need.
And when you use dollar shave clubs,
executive razor with their easy to use doc Dick Covey's easy shit.
[inaudible]
the blade gently glides giving you a smooth shave.
Dr Cabbie shaved butter.
Dr Carver's shave butter is transparent for a more precise shave
done.
Helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights. Razor bumps.
Make the smarter choice by going to dollar shave club for a limited time.
New members get their first month of the executive razor with a tube of their
doctor cubbies shave butter for only $5 with free shipping and that after that
razors or just a few bucks a month,
that's a $15 value for only five bot dollars. One more paragraph.
There are no hidden fees and no commitments canceling time you like,
you can only get this exclusive offer@dollarshaveclub.com slash pro that's
dollar shave club.com/bar Oh, thank Christ. One more.
This is like last period back when I was in school, just staring at the clock,
you know? Then you find out you've got a substitute teacher. Oh, thank God.
Thank God I don't have to think for the next 42 fucking minutes.
stamps.com everybody.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm pouring myself out selling merchandise at the end
of my shows, I'm a moron if I can figure out how to do it.
So can you stamp save you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business? I can mail any letter, any package,
just using my computer and printer and the mailman picks it up.
Avoid the hassle of the post office and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages, domestic or international.
Create your stamp stamps account and minutes online with no equipment to lease
and no longterm commitments.
Click print mail Shope Chet, and you're done. Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters of packages at your convenience. 24 seven,
seven days a week. Hi, what are you doing? I'm mailing your bench keywords.
Slash. Descriptors. Convenient, easy, reliable, flexible.
I don't even know what that means right now.
You can enjoy the stamp service with a special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstamps.com enter [inaudible]
stamps.com never go to the post office again. Hey,
you guys know Al Madrigal,
one of the cofounders of the all things comedy network. Huh?
Now that we're making fucking video content, we got to cook and show coming out.
We've got a political show coming out. We got this poker game we shot, we got,
we got shit, we got investors. It's all going great. Well listen,
Al Madrigal has a new fucking special that is, uh,
right now it's,
it premiered last Friday night on showtime and it is now on showtime on demand.
And speaking of all things, comedy is a new podcasts out from the, uh,
the wonderful NICU. Steph, it's called Nick America.
Nick interviews people from of all backgrounds about what makes them American
this week. He has comedian Faheem, Anwar,
subscribe and listen on iTunes or soundcloud on the all things comedy page.
Um, all right, let's, let's get into, uh,
let's read some shit here for the week. All right, let's do some questions here.
95 year old hockey player. Hey, Billy puck nuts.
I saw this video and thought you'd get a kick out of it.
Maybe it'll even motivate you to get your old red tits out there and keep
playing hockey. I want to, I just don't have time.
It's amazing how much good you can do to yourself just by staying active.
Anyways, here's the link and go fuck yourself.
P S thanks for making my workdays crawl by a little bit fast to the dude.
It means a lot kids. Um, anyways, yeah,
I watched this. This guy's 95 years old. He's still playing pickup hockey.
Obviously he's not flying around out there. But, uh,
that's another reason why hockey's great.
It's one of the greatest old man sports ever.
Cause you don't have to run around you just gliding, you know,
it's great cardio. It's phenomenal. Um, oh man,
in the spirit of that guy, I gotta get back out there and play.
I have not played since I played in like September or October of 2015.
I didn't play once last year. And I've yet to play this year. Um,
it's hard because we get ice time late at night and uh, you know,
I got the kid now who by the way,
I'm telling you late at night is in the morning and late at night and my two
favorite times, you know,
when she just wakes up and she's just looking at you and she's just talking all
this gibberish, smiling and all that.
And then late at night when she gets all fussy and everything when me and Nia
just sit there and totally like engage with her, you know,
she's just like the look on her face,
just completely enamored. You know, you got to understand. I mean,
I obviously you just heard me real read out loud so you know how fucking dumb I
am. So to have another human being looking at you like you have all the answers,
I mean it's, it's fucking unbelievable.
And then this fear creeps in where you just like,
what's going to happen the day she realizes I,
I really don't have any answers,
honey. Let me introduce you to the world of going with your gut. All right.
Fear of driving. Hello Billy boy.
I hope today is treating you and your family well. Well thank you.
Well just like the title says, I am completely terrified to drive a car.
By the way, that guy just went totally different.
Rather than calling me an asshole, he actually said something nice.
I'm completely terrified of driving a car.
I'm 21 and can't drive worth his shit.
And I had been lucky enough to have a family that takes me to my college for
classes, which is thankfully, thankfully is close by.
Are they helping you or enabling you?
The problem is I need my license is the last thing I need to truly be
independent.
The problem is that when I get behind the wheel to practice driving, I tense up.
Every horrible outcome pours into my stupid brain.
What if I make a mistake and get someone killed or accidentally hit a car full
of kids and kill him, kill him? I would not be able to live with myself.
So my brain just goes into hyper mode and I just start getting jittery and
really sweaty. I don't want to lose, I don't want to be this loser anymore.
Bill, any advice? Yes. Drive on Sundays.
All right. Drive to an empty parking lot.
It's hard to find them nowadays because nobody really, you know,
gives a shit about those old puritan laws. Um, back in the day,
you know, with liquor stores and you could, everybody,
like Sunday was a day arrest. So I learned how to drive.
My Dad used to take me down to the south shore plaza in a brain tree,
Massachusetts on Sundays and I learned how to drive on a like a 78 Chevys of
Chevette four speed standard transmission.
I actually took my driver's test on a stick shift and um,
they used to, you know, he used to do that with all of us.
He'd take us down there, you know, you got to a certain age,
he just take you down there, he teach you how to drive and um,
that was the way to do it.
So what I would do if I was you is I would go down there,
have your parents drive you down there and just drive around an empty parking
lot or drive down like a quiet neighborhood and you just gradually build more
and more confidence.
And the only way you get over something as you gotta face it.
So this is what I would do, right? I would just go down that, you know,
first time you just drive around there in the car the whole time. All right?
The next
time you do it, you drive around.
And when he got 10 minutes left in the driving thing, he, you just tell you day,
dad, why don't you just step out for a second? And I'll just,
same thing I did last week when I got back into flying the helicopter, you know,
I took two lessons. One I wrote, you know,
I was with the instructor the next time, once again it was with the instructor.
And then at the end of the lesson I asked him to step out and I flew it around
by myself. Gives you confidence. Yeah, my palms were sweating. I was nervous,
but you know,
okay.
I mean that it's really a metaphor in life, dude. I mean,
he kinda got to face this type of shit. So, um,
yeah.
If I was you considering you have such a fear, no pun intended,
I would totally steer into this.
You could take a defensive driving course and then I bet there's actually,
I don't know where you live, but sometimes you know, they have like these, uh,
okay.
I know out here they have like,
they have a course out here where they'll teach you how to do all like that shit
from the movies. Like spin the car around. I mean,
why don't you go from being totally terrified,
you just becoming a fucking expert. You know,
learn how to do burnouts and all of that shit,
then you become an absolute terror on the fucking road. Learn how to drift,
you know, just master the shit as much as you can.
And then driving down the street will be a joke.
And as far as like killing a bunch of kids and everything like that,
the level of technology nowadays with like the airbags and all that,
you don't sound like you're going to be driving super fast.
So the worst thing going to do is just crumple up some fenders. That's all. Um,
but you could do it. You just get out there. So just, yeah,
baby steps, baby steps. That's all you gotta do.
I'm flying again this week. I'm flying on Tuesday. Um,
and then uh, I got some other family coming in.
I'm going to take some people up this weekend going up with instructor.
I've yet to have the balls to bring a passenger up,
even though I know I could do it. I can't take a family member up.
I was joking with a buddy of mine, Jay law head.
I think I'm going to take him up first.
[inaudible]
I was like, dude,
I have to deal with the pressure of just the love I have for a friend.
Forget about an actual family member of my wife or something like that.
So anyways, all right. So that's what I would do.
So dude is I get over my fear of uh, you know, bringing up a passenger.
You know, you, you update me, I'll update you. All right. Um,
so good luck. You could do it man. All right. Ex-Girlfriend's blanket.
Hey Billy Boo Radley. I have a question for you.
My ex-girlfriend's grandmother made me a blanket for Christmas and I kept it
after we broke up.
We broke up a little over six years ago and my current girlfriend and I have
been together ever since.
We just had our six year anniversary and are talking about getting married.
My ex just got married last week and brought up the question of the blanket,
wait a minute. You broke up with this woman years ago.
You still have the blanket. She just got married.
It's six years later and she just brought up the question,
meaning you're still in contact with her
[inaudible]
should we get rid of the blanket?
I don't think you meant to say your ex. I think no human humans.
You mean your current one?
He just lost my ex-girlfriend's grandmother made me a blanket for Christmas and
I kept it after we broke up, broke up a little over six years ago.
My current girlfriend and I had been together ever since.
We just had six year anniversary and we're talking about getting married.
My ex just got married last week. Oh,
and that brought up the question of the blanket. I'm sorry. Jesus.
Poor bastards probably listened to this podcast. Scorn. I said that.
I said that in the sentence. All right,
should we get rid of the blanket? It wouldn't.
It wouldn't that big. It wouldn't be that big a deal,
but my ex grandmother stitch our names and our anniversary into it.
Oh my God, Dude. What the fuck?
It's like a championship banner for your former relationship. Also,
my current girlfriend and I really liked the blanket.
It's the color of the college
where my current girlfriend and I first met.
And we have a lot of memories having Minnesota blizzards under the blanket too.
This is so fucking weird.
Your new girlfriend snuggled under a blanket with your name and your past
girlfriends name. It's your anniversary date on it.
My current girlfriends from California,
and these were some of the first blizzard she had seen.
So it was a special experience for her. What should we do with the blanket?
I think you should keep it. You're fucking Weirdos.
I don't know any advice to it. This is the weirdest fucking shit ever.
So my ex girlfriend just got married last weekend.
That brought up the question of the blanket from who you both see the Lichen.
Jesus Christ.
Why don't you make a Voodoo doll of your fucking ex-girlfriend and spoon with
the between the two? Yeah. And have a threesome. Um,
we would appreciate your advice as we are both fans of the podcast and your
stand up. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Yeah,
you guys are fucking bizarre when it comes to that.
Jesus Christ. Why don't you just put in a fucking sex tape?
You guys made a, I don't know, maybe I read it wrong.
Maybe I was being too harsh. I Apologize, but ah, that's just fucking weird. Uh,
dad kicked off Delta flight, dear illiterate.
Cont ah, there you go. That's, that's usual intro that I'm used to. Um,
have you seen the video of the guy in his family getting kicked off a Delta
Airlines flight the other day? The video is long, but worth watching and full.
At one point they threatened to put him and his wife in jail and his kids in
foster care. What is going on?
My first question is,
what the hell is going on in the past week with all these air airplane
incidents, the Asian guy getting his ass kicked gala was brutal.
Some young brides not being allowed
to board due to wearing yoga pants
in the world's largest rabbit dying and transport under a plane. Well, I mean,
you know, that can happen. Why is this suddenly a trend? Uh, secondly,
I have to commend the father for his overall attitude and demeanor in the video.
While I,
while watching I couldn't help but wonder how it all would have went down.
And if an angry east coast father who were in this guy's shoes,
can you imagine an angry father driving to the airport with his bitchy wife and
wining Tyler searching for parking, getting the car seat out of the car,
pushing a stroller through security,
hauling your shit all the way to the gate boarding and then being told they sold
your seat to someone else and you either have to hold your kid the entire flight
or get off the fucking plane.
Sounds more like an episode of is for family than it does reality.
Just wanting to share. Hope you in the lovely Nia.
Keep your DVR relationship afloat in your flooded house. Um,
yeah, I think it's time for other passages to speak up.
Everybody just sits there silently as they yank these people off the plane.
Um, I don't understand why like
it's like, yeah, we sold this to someone else.
It's like you also sold it to me and I have my receipt, my ticket,
and I'm on this flight. So you're trying to say that someone else is,
more importantly,
I would do is I would sue the fucking shit out of that airline.
They need to be sued because it's their fuck up and they're making it somebody
else's.
They make it the customer's fault and the level of trauma that they're bringing
to people. Like right now, you know something.
Why don't we all just fire off angry fucking letters to United and Delta?
Why don't we get organized? Why don't, I mean,
if anybody could send me the link where to do that, you know,
the problem is, is if they're all fucking doing it, then where do you go?
You go to southwest. Southwest hasn't done anything like that. Have they?
American hasn't done it. United has done it. Delta has done it.
So fuck both of them.
Fuck both of those airlines until they learn how to treat people right and Jesus
Christ and they learn how to count. How many seats you got,
how many tickets did you sell? Well, there you go. Um,
no that you, I don't know man. The problem is is they're,
they're an organized entity. And that the passengers are not,
I remember that flyers rights thing was going down a while ago.
Can that thing be like revived and uh,
when they start to yank somebody off with their fucking children,
I mean that's, no one wants that to happen to them.
That, that shouldn't, that shouldn't,
it shouldn't be able to bully people like that.
If you make a mistake as an airline,
you should eat the cost instead of passing it on to everybody else.
Like to have security go down there.
If they ever do that to me, I'm going to be like, I'm not leaving.
I'm not leaving.
If you physically removed me from my seat that I paid for and I have the
receipt, I've done nothing wrong. I'm not a threat. I'm ready to fly.
I'm going to sue, I'm going to sue. I'm like, I can't say the living shit.
I'm going to sue you guys. You know? I mean,
how do they at least give them miles? Did they do anything anymore?
I Dunno. Cooperations are a, they're a fucking disease.
They're completely out of control and they have no,
the only thing they have sympathy and empathy for is the bottom line.
That's all they care about. And if you work in those worlds, like um,
I understand if you're on the lower levels, you know you're not about that.
But in those upper levels, you guys, I dunno, I dunno how you'd do it,
but you guys, you pieces of shit that you could do that, you know,
if I fucking,
if somehow that ever happened at one of my comedy shows is no fucking way,
I'm letting that person get kicked out. There's no fucking way. Find a chair.
Okay,
fucking let the person sit on the side of the stage.
This chairs on the side of the stairs always, you know,
for the union guys that get fucking,
get one of those chairs and hand it to the parcel.
I'm sitting on the side of the stage, take a picture. You fucking,
when you fuck up like that, it's up to you digitally.
The exact opposite of what they should be doing.
You know,
don't kick the person off. Whoever you fucked over,
you give him whatever you have to give him in the airport.
If they have some sort of Ah, you know, place they have to be,
you got to figure out how to get them there. You know,
offer enough to people.
There's going to be some single dude who's got nothing to go home to other than
a fucking futon. Just be like, dude, we'll get you a 12 pack.
We'll give you 30,000 fucking miles. We wouldn't give a shit.
You're a fucking multimillion dollar. There's a way to do it. Right.
Okay.
If I was running an airline that way, it would just, you know,
I'd have a guy come on tress like a fucking game show host. All right.
It'd be like, I got cash in my suit pocket.
You know, I have a couple of hot chicks dress like bunnies, you know,
that will fucking walk you down, you know? Or if you gay, you know,
you're gay dude, Eto. I have a couple of fucking shredded tanned up guys.
Shirtless. Whatever the fuck you want.
It'd be the greatest walk he ever had up to fucking tarmac. You know,
give you a stack of cash like fucking Henry Hill. You know,
why don't you do it that way instead of coming down fucking all knees and elbows
and gorilla and some gorilla. Somebody off a fucking plane. It's so stupid.
All right, boyfriend troubles. Hey Bill.
I was wondering if you could help with issues I'm having with my boyfriend. Uh,
he's really sweet, but sometimes too sweet. Now Jesus,
he's too submissive and I wish he could be more dominant. All right.
Okay. He's fucking, he would give up his seat. Is that what you're saying?
I don't know how to bring it up to him without hurting his feelings.
I really want to do BDSM bondage. Sado
Masochists wait, the screen just went out. Rape role play,
but every time we try it, it never works.
Yeah.
Oh. Oh. Can I top off? Toughen them up.
Oh my God. That's a fucking sketch right there. He's too sweet. You know,
he's a sweet, nice guy and you want to do that with this sweet, nice guy.
Hey [inaudible]
don't move or I'll, uh, I'll pop you on your head.
Okay.
How do you got to speak a little more firmer than that?
I will bop you on the head. Stop saying, Bob, you're drying me up.
Um, I'm, can I toughen them up? You know what, you can't, you can't,
uh, what you're looking to do. Uh, you can't do it with the person like that.
You just got understand that he's a square peg trying to fit into a round hole.
They'll fucking pun intended. And, uh,
I dunno, I, I, you know,
it's like that whole sex thing. You gotta like, you guys,
you gotta vibe with each other. If the vibe isn't there,
especially with something like that, I mean, that's gonna be,
that's gonna be the most awkward thing ever.
Do you do the whole act out? Do you tell them to go outside and try to like,
you know, he probably knocked on the door, hello here to rape you,
if that's okay. Um, uh, yeah, yeah.
You're, you're with, I would say you with the wrong guy. That's all. Um,
so you gotta you know, I don't know. I don't, I have no idea.
I don't know what to tell you.
Um,
yeah, I'm going to leave it at that. I really need Nia here.
You know,
that's just like a whole, I don't know that you can do that.
Is there any woman out there? Have you been able to,
cause I got to tell you from the other side when I want to back in the day when
I was a single man, you know,
glory days pass you by voting things the way you're [inaudible].
Um,
okay.
Oh what I would do,
well I guess you've already done this so it's not working on it.
What I would always do when you are trying to like get a woman to not be so sick
, cause it was really with a lot of women, they're super self conscious.
It's like they don't know what they want to do or want to try.
It's they're so of how
a guy that they actually like is going to judge them.
So what I did was I would just gradually,
I would just create this environment where it's just like, yeah,
I'm not going to, I'm not going to judge you.
I don't go whatever the fuck you want to do. And I really believe that. I mean,
just like I don't judge anybody, whatever the fuck they want to do with Viet,
that's what you're in to. Go ahead and do it.
So long as the other person's also went to what they know. That's fine.
So you had to create this environment where they weren't afraid to say what they
wanted to try, which I used to say you would drawing out their inner whore,
which is still judgmental.
You really want what you're doing as you freed them up. Um, you know,
it's like free gift free. Getting free is freeing up as a comedian. You know,
you just sort of leave your act behind. He just, you know,
you bomb a little bit, then you get relaxed.
Then you find trying to free yourself up on an instrument.
I imagine the same way. There's no difference. Same thing in the bedroom.
However, um,
okay.
What the fuck is that noise? That my phone.
Oh yes it is. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Um, anyways. All right, I gotta get off the phone here. So, um,
wow.
There are certain people they don't have like what you're,
what you're looking for that this person probably doesn't have in them.
So I don't know what to tell you. Um,
but I mean, if you haven't done anything else,
you kind of started way down the fucking road. You know what I mean?
Jesus quite just having slap your ass a little bit. I mean, fucking baby steps.
Go rent. What about Bob? Learn about baby steps and maybe you could gradually,
you know,
yeah,
take this sweet innocent person and turn them into a fucking DV and I have no
idea. I don't know what to tell Ya. Um,
yeah.
Uh, unfortunately Nia is still sleeping downstairs, so I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you. It's been my experience that,
you know,
I don't know if someone's not into it then on until you just fucking leave it at
that, right. It's not what it is. Jesus. This is awkward.
All right. That's the podcast.
That's the podcast. Go Celtics. How about the fucking prejudice?
First one's too advanced to the conference. Finals. Beaten me,
began Saint Louis Louis Blues. Go home couplets once again. Once again,
50 fucking years. No Cup. Um,
the Edmonton Oilers coming back after that brutal fucking loss and overtime,
um,
Jesus is going to be Edmonton and the predators is going to be the ducks.
Oh God. I don't know. I just never been in, I just could never get over.
I've never forgiven them for being owned by Disney and named after a kids movie,
the mighty ducks.
Okay.
You know, maybe if they still had the fucking intestinal fortitude,
as he always used to say in wrestling to still call themselves the mighty ducks.
Okay. The fact that they got to where they got rid of the mighty, you know,
it's like they're trying to run from the history. It's like KFC,
your Kentucky Fried Chicken. You know,
stop trying to fucking lighten it up. Um,
squeeze a minute. Who the fuck is left? Yeah.
I still think the penguins are going to do it. You know. Crosby's come back.
Seems to be all right, I think. Depends. Got It. Uh,
and I can say that I haven't watched 10 games this year. All right.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll check on a, on Thursday. All right.